les prolonge croyais que c'était pas
méchant j'ai appris aussi que les pousse
à sauter pas dans les cheveux les idées
reçues sur les petites bêtes qui nous
entourent françois lasserre les
décortique ce spécialiste des insectes
invite à réfléchir il animé hier un
goûter science est ce que quelqu'un sait
qu'il ya encore
me suis rendu compte moi quand je suis
devenu grand moi même que les grandes
avait raconté c'est actuellement
n'importe quoi sur les araignées ou sur
les bestioles
on manque beaucoup d'esprit critique et
de démarche scientifique
on est un peu irrationnel et avoir
croire qu'une araignée nous a mordu au
piquet alors que personne n'a jamais vu
faire et que la personnelle n'est pas
arachnologues est le point de départ de
l'atelier entre voir l'invisible le nom
de l'exposition temporaire de la
commanderie des templiers
ici l'artiste ma flou et passe doué vous
entraîne dans un cabinet des curiosités
chercher un peu une définition à
visibles et donc elles seront du coup on
passait beaucoup la visible c'est
beaucoup de facettes c'est ce qu'on voit
pas parce que c'est trop petit trop loin
ce qu on s'empêche de voir ce qu'on ne
voit ce qu'on voit différemment des
autres pour mettre en pratique les
leçons de françois lasserre sur les
petites bêtes qui font peur mais pas
trop il vous emmène en sortie le 3 juin
prochain à magny les hameaux